>> ♪ ♪
>> Laura: IMMIGRATION CRISIS
MIGHT BE BREWING FOR HOUSE
SPEAKER PAUL RYAN AND HIS
HEADERSHIP TEAM.
THE HOUSE IS JUST 5 GOP VOTES
AWAY FROM BRINGING SEVERAL
DIFFERENT DACA BILLS TO THE
FLOOR TO GO AROUND HOUSE
LEADERSHIP.
GOP LEADERS FEAR THIS COULD COST
THE PARTY CONTROL OF THE HOUSE.
HERE IS REPUBLICAN JEFF DENHAM
WHO SUPPORTS THE MANEUVER AND
REPUBLICAN SEAN DUFFY WHO
OPPOSES IT.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
WE WILL GET INTO THE TRICKS,
QUEEN OF THE HILL AND DISCHARGE
PETITION, WE WILL LOSE THE
AUDIENCE.
CONGRESSMAN YOU ARE IN FAVOR OF
TURNING THE HOUSE FLOOR OVER TO
NANCY PELOSI TO DEBATE THIS?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL.
>> Laura: BUT TURN THE DEBATE
OVER TO THE DEMOCRATS?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL.
WE HAVE A REPUBLICAN MAJORITY.
WE CONTROL ALL OF THE RULES.
PAUL RYAN HAS HIS OWN BILL.
THE PRESIDENT HAS A BILL.
YES, THE DEMOCRATS GET A BILL
TOO.
WE WILL DO WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
ASKING FOR HIM AND GIVE HIM
BORDER SECURITY.
WE CAN'T WAIT ANY LONGER --
EVERY YEAR THAT GOES BY, ANOTHER
HALF MILLION PEOPLE COME ACROSS
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE 8 YEARS SEAN AND I HAVE BEEN
IN OFFICE TOGETHER THAT'S 4
MILLION PEOPLE FROM DOING
NOTHING.
>> Laura: LOOK AT SEAN DUFFY, HE
IS PRACTICALLY BUILDING THE WALL
HIMSELF.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> I DON'T LIKE THE TACTIC.
JEFF KNOWS THAT.
I THINK THIS TURNS THE FLOOR
OVER TO WHAT IS CALLED THE QUEEN
OF THE HILL.
YOU PUT UP FOUR BILLS, THE ONE
THAT GETS THE MAJORITY PASSES.
WE HAVE A WIDE AGREEMENT ON
TRUMP'S 4 PILLARS.
THAT WILL PASS.
JEFF WILL VOTE FOR THAT.
THE FREEMEN  -- FREEDOM CAUCUS
WILL VOTE FOR THAT.
>> Laura: YOU ARE WORRIED ABOUT
THE FARMERS AND THE WORKERS.
YOU HAVE TO STOP CHAIN
MIGRATION.
THAT'S A MASS MULTIPLIER OF
IMMIGRATION INTO THE UNITED
STATES WITH DISTANT RELATIVES
COMING INTO THE COUNTRY WITHOUT
MERIT.
CHAIN MIGRATION AND BUILD THE
WALL AND REFORM THE ASYLUM
PROCESS.
THAT'S ALL IN THE BILL.
YOU DON'T NEED FOUR BILLS.
>> WE DON'T HAVE THE BALLS FOR
THAT BILL.
DONALD TRUMP SAID I WANT TO
BUILD A WALL.
LET'S COME TOGETHER FOR 25
BILLION DOLLARS AND BUILD THE
WALL AND MAKE OTHER TWEAKS.
WE WILL DEAL WITH DACA.
THAT'S A PACKAGE THAT THE
PRESIDENT WANTS.
IT'S GENEROUS FOR THE DACA KIDS
BUT GIVES US BORDER SECURITY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN IN
THE SENATE.
>> I CAN'T SUPPORT THE GOOD LAT
BILL.
>> Laura: WHY?
>> I DIDN'T SUPPORT PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S EXECUTIVE ORDER.
I THOUGHT IT WAS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
JUST DOING AN EXTENSION OF
OBAMA'S POLICY 3 YEARS DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE.
WE NEED TO FIX THE WALL AND FIX
SOME PROBLEMS AND HAVE A
PERMANENT FIX.
>> Laura: YOU DON'T WANT TO
BUILD THE WALL?
>> ABSOLUTELY I DO.
>> Laura: THE WHOLE WALL?
>> YES, OF COURSE.
>> Laura: THE ONLY PROBLEM YOU
HAVE IS WITH THE AMNESTY OF
800,000?
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER.
>> Laura: OBAMA DIDN'T DEAL WITH
CHAIN MIGRATION.
CHAIN MIGRATION YOU CHANGE THE
GAME WITH IMMIGRATION.
>> BUT HE CHANGED THE DYNAMIC
FOR KIDS THAT GO TO OUR HIGH
SCHOOL UNCONSTITUTIONAL HE.
IF WE ARE GOING TO FIX THIS.
IT'S AN AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Laura: THIS WILL DIVIDE THE
PARTY BEFORE THE MID-TERM
ELECTION.
>> THIS IS WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
ASKING FOR.
>> Laura: HE WANTS THE END OF
CHAIN MIGRATION AND WANTS THE
WALL BUILD AND TO END THE VISA
LOTTERY.
>> HE SAID IF WE DON'T HAVE THIS
DONE, HE DOESN'T WANT TO SEE THE
CR.
>> THE PROBLEM WITH THE DACA
KIDS, IF YOU DON'T END CHAIN
MIGRATION, THE KIDS AND THE
PARENTS WHO BROUGHT THEM IN GET
LEGAL STATUS.
>> Laura: THE PARENTS ARE ALL
STAYING.
LET'S BE HONEST.
>> WE HAVE TO FIX THAT PART WITH
DACA.
>> Laura: DONALD TRUMP DID NOT
WIN ON GIVING AMNESTY TO THE
DACA KIDS.
HE WON ON BORDER SECURITY.
BUILDING A WALL AND EVEN
CALIFORNIA THE MAJORITY WANT
DEPORTATION TO GO ON.
THE BERKELEY POLL IS
DEVASTATING.
59% SAID IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
START DEPORTING THESE PEOPLE.
>> THE PRESIDENT PUT THE
DEMOCRATS ON NOTICE.
THE DEMOCRATS HAD 42 BILLION OUT
OF EVERY DEMOCRAT IN THE HOUSE.
PUT THEM TO THE TEST ON THIS
ISSUE.
>> AS WE REPUBLICANS WE DON'T
WANT TO TURN THIS OVER TO THE
NANCY PELOSI.
I DON'T THINK WE WILL LOSE IN
THE HOUSE.
LET'S GET A FAMILY SOLUTION.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT
PROCESS.